rampage was directed by Brad Payton and
stars
Dwayne Johnson and Naomi Harris and is
based off the midway series of video
games that began in 1986 with the arcade
game rampage which was eventually ported
over to the NES the basic premise of the
games was that you were a human that was
turned into a giant monster after being
experimented on and you could control
that monster and destroy cities that was
all it was just being a monster leveling
cities it was a blast I've always
enjoyed the rampage games and so I was
excited to see what could happen on the
big screen when it came to adapting this
even though video game movies
historically don't really go over very
well and in this adaptation Dwayne
Johnson plays a primatologist who shares
a unique bond with a gorilla named
George he knows sign language they
communicate with each other they care
for each other but when a scientific
experiment goes awry George gets
infected with it as well as a reptile
and a wolf they get gigantic and they
all come to Chicago to destroy it and
the only one that can save the city and
hopefully George is the rock I'll put it
this way if you saw San Andreas or
journey to the mysterious island both
films have starred Dwayne Johnson both
films that were directed by Brad Payton
just like rampage you know pretty much
what this movie's gonna feel like all
three of those movies are the definition
of popcorn films they're not going to
leave much of an impact they're
watchable but in the end you're probably
going to forget about them and when it
comes to rampage that's pretty much how
I felt this is an extremely cheesy film
with some truly awful dialogue and
characters that make decisions at the
last minute that solve all of their
problems mass death is not taken very
seriously in the film some deaths are
even portrayed as a pratfall like for a
laugh which was a little off-putting but
for the most part I feel like most
people are going to go to rampage to
watch monsters destroy cities which I
know that's why I went because that's
what the game is unfortunately you have
to tread through a lot of movie to get
to any of that which is really just the
last 20 minutes which can be taken at
face value you can take a gigantic pile
of popcorn and just put it on your face
and watch the last 20 minutes of rampage
and probably enjoy it but everything up
until that felt like a Michael Bay movie
there are so many jokes that don't land
they are like three or four characters
introduced in the first act that
disappear and are never heard from again
I like Jeffrey Dean Morgan I think he's
very talented you've heard of people
chewing up the scenery I'm pretty sure
Jeffrey Dean Morgan actually ate this
whole movie because his character is so
larger-than-life and that's one of my
biggest issues with the film the human
beings in this movie actually feel more
like videogame characters than the
monsters Jeffrey Dean Morgan especially
but the rock holy shit this guy survives
everything he gets in a helicopter on
top of a building that's crumbling and
he just comes up with a plan and it just
works
things like this happen throughout the
entire film this guy is a human punching
bag he gets beat up every two seconds
and somehow survives but there's no
realism to it it's not like a film like
say die hard where you understand that
John McClane is within a few inches of
his life but the way it's told is
serious and realistic and you can buy
into it
and rampage things happen that would
only happen in a video game and it's
being transferred from a video game and
so perhaps that's why they felt it was
okay but I feel like this film was so
far fetched I just started to check out
but easily the aspect of the film I
didn't care for the most were the
villains this movie needed to have an
excuse for this scientific experiment
that made all of this chaos happen so we
have two people who work at this agency
who don't give a shit about anybody who
want to see the world destroyed for
money their motivation is money and we
cut back to them constantly and they
might as well be like stroking a giant
mustache and just going like this and
and laughing like they're a Bond villain
from the 1960s it was really bad and the
performances didn't work either and one
of the most hilarious parts of these
villains is that they have an actual
arcade coin-op cabinet for rampage in
their office and you can see it clear as
day in multiple shots I get that it's an
easter egg because this movie's rampage
but why in the world do these higher-ups
at this company who only care about
people's money and are sending three
monsters to Chicago to destroy the city
for no reason other than they want to
sell stuff and get rich why do they have
a rampage arcade machine in their office
I've always liked the rock I like him in
his wrestling days I've liked him in his
acting days he is easily one of the most
charismatic and likable guys working in
film there's a reason he's as famous as
he is and he certainly is not the
problem here the real issue is the
screenplay
it also doesn't give much of anything
for Naomi Harris to do who basically
runs around asking the rock constantly
what's the plan what's the plan what's
the plan every once in a while she'll
figure out some tech device that she
maybe knows from this place she used to
work and she can work that real quick
she busts through glass once in a unique
way but for the most part she's just
running around going like this trying to
figure out what to do looking to the
rock for leadership and it just got
really old after a while the characters
in the movie are more video game
characters than the actual monsters and
I just wanted to see them destroy a city
and have a big battle that's one of my
biggest problems with the video game
adaptations the studio's that try to
adapt to video games they don't know why
people like the video games that's one
of the reasons I like the newest Tomb
Raider it felt like the game with this
film it's like yeah you can't really
make a feature-length movie with just
monsters destroying cities after a while
it'll get monotonous you have to have
some people involved but all of the
worst video game adaptations don't
understand why the video games
themselves are as good as they are and
they try to add all this stuff that the
video game fans don't even want to see
and I won't spoil it of course but the
ending of the film leaves so many
questions if you think about it for more
than 30 seconds and it just feels like
the studio was really hoping you
wouldn't do that again you don't go to
rampage expecting poetry or Shakespeare
or you know oscar-worthy filmmaking but
I think sometimes writers get together
and and they hope that you don't expect
that and they hope that you will give
that past of the film that oh it's okay
you're not supposed to take it seriously
and that's kind of what it felt like
what the
Reiter's it just felt like they weren't
really taking it seriously this could
have been a really fun guilty pleasure
style movie and in the end it's just a
movie that audiences are going to go to
and turn their brains off and forget
about within seconds for some that might
be all you wanted as a fan of the games
I think I wanted a little bit more I
wanted some more care to the human
beings in the movie one really cool
choice that would have really helped the
film in the games as I said you're a
person that's transformed into a monster
it's not just like random animals that
got really big like in the film that
would have added more depth that would
have made it more morally confusing like
do we try to destroy this monster or is
there a way that we try to stop it
because we know it's a person like
there's just that would have been a
really interesting moral dilemma in the
middle of this movie where monsters are
destroying cities which again I must say
that's what I wanted to see and when
that happened the movie was really fun
everything else though leading up to
that was just really bland I'm gonna
give rampage a c-minus like I said if
you've seen Brad Peyton's other films
with the rock journey to the mysterious
island or San Andreas you can probably
guess what rampage is going to be like
and I think I wanted a little bit more
out of it guys thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]